when we set out to create the next
generation of NHL our first priority was
to fully rebuild our players from the
inside out utilizing the power of
next-gen consoles each player has now
been constructed using three distinct
layers the body the equipment and the
Jersey dynamic cloth adds another layer
of realism jerseys contour to the body
and move just like they're supposed to
allowing for more authentic contact with
the puck and the players on the surface
these layered player models transform
into the players in Dillon love to a
federal player likeness emotion and
animation from the grimace on a player's
face after they've taken a big hit to
the pure jubilation that comes to
scoring a game-winning goal these
athletes will come to life with every
play
all new user controlled celebrations
allow you to put your personal touch on
every goal you score go in for a group
hug and celebrate with your teammates or
plan up for the home crowd after a
series clincher when it comes to the
players in NHL 15
literally changed everything stay tuned
for more jab diaries featuring gameplay
improvements living worlds and the
all-new broadcasted NHL 15 experience
the next generation of hockey for
yourself when ain't shelled 15 drops
September 9